let's go to Vitali from Iowa Vitale from
Iowa welcome to the David packman show
hi David can you hear me yes I can
all right uh so I have uh you might have
gotten this question before but
um
I am sort of along the lines uh where
you are I would consider myself more of
a Social Democrat and uh I
I've encountered a lot of my peers who
are more along the lines of uh
Democratic socialists anarcho Communists
Etc and uh
there's a lot of infighting uh I even
get called right wing sometimes okay so
I was wondering uh what you would say to
that and how to stop all this infighting
that's going on well these are two very
different questions if I as a Social
Democrat were called right wing I would
do what I already do which is to say
tell me which positions of mine are
right wing and that usually grinds the
conversation to a halt because it's very
hard to name positions of mine that are
right wing so at the individual level of
Italy I when people call you right wing
because you're a Social Democrat and not
a socialist ask them to enumerate your
right wing positions you know what I'm
saying
sure sure now in terms of more generally
about reducing the infighting I have
absolutely no idea
um the the reality is that
the infighting on the right
I believe is more uh prevalent right now
than than on the left even though it's
very popular to say the left has all
this infighting it's true you can find
people on the left who if you don't
subscribe to every idea about all of
these issues what what usually with
cultural issues there is a slice of the
left which will say you're not really on
the left but it's actually relatively
small whereas on the right the Maga
versus anti-maga stuff is really ugly
and we'll see to what extent it's
destructive but it's lost them a bunch
of Elections so far so I mean listen
it'd be great if the the entire left can
get on the same page and then we all
sing Kumbaya and all of this stuff the
reality is that there's a spectrum of
the left from Center left Democrats all
the way out to you know leninist left
and revolutionary left and socialist and
all these different things if we're
really honest most of the left is on the
same page when it comes to a particular
election who are we better off with and
that doesn't mean some people don't stay
home or protest Vote or whatever the
case may be but I I actually think the
left is quite United
all right
um
yeah thank you for your Insight David I
just want to say I've been a
subscriber for a few years now and you
were actually uh you helped uh pulled me
out of the Maga right so I just want to
say thank you sir well thank you for
your service I appreciate it yes all
right there it goes Vitale from Iowa
with a very powerful declaration I love
my Helix sleep mattress I've been
sleeping on Helix mattresses for years
now which is why I asked them to be a
sponsor you actually take their famous
sleep quiz takes just a few minutes to
answer questions about your sleep
preferences body type sleep position
whether you have back pain and Helix
will match you with a mattress that's
perfect for you which is really unique
and helpful because a lot of people
don't know where to start when buying a
mattress I certainly didn't their newest
collection of mattresses called Helix
Elite come with a built-in glaciotext
layer to keep you cool at night an extra
layer of foam for pressure relief and
thousands of extra micro coils for Best
in Class support and durability all of
their mattresses ship right to your door
totally free they come with a 10 or 15
year warranty and you get 100 90 to
decide if you like it my audience gets a
huge 25 discount on all purchases plus
two free pillows go to helixsleep.com
Pacman and enter the code
helixpartner25 at checkout the link is
down below